papa lorraine is an incredible creative
mind
pablo is such an artist
he's a visionary i come from the wall of
cinema where things are condensed to two
hours
here the invitation was to do an
eight-hour episodic television show
[Music]
stephen king is someone who's been able
to understand
our humanity in a very universal way
the last 50 years of our culture
have been somehow shaped by these
[Music]
stories
i went to maine and i stayed at stephen
kiss house
which was a very fascinating experience
reading and kind of going over the
scripts trying for me to understand
what you know what he really was looking
for that maybe was not exactly on the
page
i personally struggled at the beginning
i wanted to take everything to a more
grounded sort of space where the
narrative was more
naturalistic and realistic
and he was like no you have to come to
my world
where all the things happen to the
characters they do travel to different
worlds and different realities
[Music]
so i had to go as a filmmaker through a
process of embrace that narrative
and it's funny because it's somehow what
happens to the main character as well
this story is a story of a woman who's
trying to put herself together
to move on with her life lisey doesn't
want to admit that that world exists or
that kind of things can happen it's
wonderful for me as a filmmaker
because you have to find a way to create
certain layers
of a narrative that is based on this
fragmented memory
[Music]
memories combined and mixed with fantasy
and that fantasy goes into the real
world and
vice versa it was just a fascinating
process
to embrace the fantasy and the
psychological horror
in a way that has some poetry and some
beauty
this journey of humanity will take us to
pain sorrow beauty family love
a lot of darkness and a lot of light and
healing
the experience of doing this it really
changed me and made me a different
filmmaker so i'm very grateful
why are they so important to you
because stories are all i had
[Music]
you